all right what's going on
hey rich how you going doing good doing
good what are you going for pleasure
pleasure to meet you um they're a long
time listener i appreciate all the work
that you've been doing for everyone over
the years so
um yeah the story that i've got is um
yeah about three three and a half years
ago started seeing this girl
and uh things sort of fell off and uh
she kind of um you know broke away from
me and um
yeah for a really long time i was i
guess you could say carrying the bag of
bricks sort of beating myself up but i
knew that fundamentally
i had to sort of look within and do some
of the work to sort of improve myself
and then ended up getting a new job
ended up getting more pay
you know kept hitting the gym and
continually working on myself
it was about a week a week and a half
ago i was at a sales conference
interstate
uh and i ended up running into her on a
late friday night with another guy
and uh
she was with another guy
yeah she was with another guy and it was
like it was this kind of moment that i
was like i can't believe that i like
punished myself for so long because of
this woman and she's just out like with
another dude like literally getting
passed around in a different state and
it was like it was just a bit of like a
you know kind of [ __ ] like [ __ ] with my
head sort of moment
and uh yeah i guess like
you know talking about on the subject it
was like i complicated my life for so
long you know beating myself up over it
and
um sort of
pointing the finger of myself thinking
that there was something wrong with me
where in reality like
these like she's 33 like
literally getting passed around you know
it's like kind of like public property
almost look man i've i've seen it happen
in the course of 24 hours i've seen i've
seen women move from being intimate with
me to another dude within a course of 24
hours no shame whatsoever
completely try to hide it even if it's
exposed doesn't matter i'm a woman so
you know i get away with whatever i want
it's just like who cares you know like
like
you know to the point of the show on
complicating life and justifying why
that again you know there's a lot of
people that spend a lot of time with oh
well you know she does it because of
this that and the other thing and it's
like the whole thing with the dog [ __ ]
right what kind of relationship does a
dog have with the owner how old is the
dog what's the breed what did they have
for dinner for last night all that stuff
doesn't matter it's [ __ ] same thing with
her it's [ __ ] okay you don't need to
deal with that and then there's other
people to be like well you know you have
to work on your inside and this that and
the other thing and you probably get
this problem they try to like convince
you that you're [ __ ] up
and the truth of matter is you probably
aren't right
you're probably just
spending too much your time resources
and energy focused on one nightmare of a
check because you have an unhealthy
attachment to her because you didn't
have better options
okay maybe things were going your way at
work and you and you're not like the
best version of yourself at your age
group in your demographic in your city
making the kind of money that you should
be making you're not seeing red flags
when they come at you you invite them
into your life instead of repelling them
right very simple basic con you know
concepts and if you just
you know sanitize
away all the nonsense and you distill it
like you know like one of the things
that i find interesting you know now
that my book's been out is it's like
it's a 200 pager it's less than five
hours on audible i've basically taken
everything
that i saw was the most useful
information that i came across on my end
personally and
as a collection of note taking with all
the guys that i was dealing with on
consults 101
and i distilled it all down and i
sanitized all the [ __ ] off it like all
the [ __ ] fillers that you hear
especially in the mano swamp a lot you
know a lot of these guys and i just got
rid of all the junk and i sanitize it
down to the best stuff and i think
that's why the book is
doing
you know so many favors for so many guys
today it's because it's simplified
and
if i were to do a revised update on it i
would probably simplify it even further
right i mean the follow-up book that i'm
going to do to it is is going to be very
very similar to that one as well like
whatever concepts that i'm going to talk
about it's not going to be complicated
it's going to be simplified to the
[ __ ] point on the most important
stuff that you need and it's the same
thing with your life as a guy i mean if
you want to live your life as an
unplugged alpha and like really you know
have the best experience that you
possibly can like you talk about like
these things like maslow's hierarchy of
needs right with the top being the
self-actualization sort of thing
a self-actualized man an unplugged man
you know if you will
does not complicate his life
unnecessarily with you know things that
are going to throw him off as you know
trajectory
right
let's just just move on
and just like
another compliment to your book is your
clips channel funny sort of story my
brother you know i i have a younger
brother and i try to sort of be that old
older brother kind of influence him and
uh he notices that i listen to you a lot
and uh you know probably about a year
ago he was sort of making fun of me he's
like why do you listen to this bitter
guy on the internet but i'm like dude
he's an older guy like he's kind of you
know has the experience like give give
it some give it a chance and would you
believe it like a couple of months ago
he'll be sending me a text message with
like a link to like one of your clips or
stuff like that so it slowly like kind
of sinks into him as well like kind of
having that mentality so yeah a lot of
guys struggle with new information that
frees them
it's overwhelming at times like this
because because society is a female
first primary social order that's
designed to protect women and
and use men basically you know men are
disposable women are protected so when
men start hearing things about putting
themselves first and maybe shining a
light on
you know specific traits about female
nature that aren't particularly
flattering
they resist like bro like i had a
conversation with a
a good friend over the weekend about his
relationship with his father and you
know his old man struggles with um
you know the newfound reality that he
lives within you know he thinks that
there's something wrong with him or that
he's joined a cult or whatever and it's
like
these things can cause you know like you
can coexist with family
that don't support your mission that
don't like you know your new beliefs and
you can still use these beliefs to serve
you better
right yeah right like nobody's cramming
it down your throat you know it's a
choice right like unplugging is a choice
yeah i mean sometimes like even when i
hang out with my dad like he'll just say
some [ __ ] and i'm just like
yeah that's not really how the world
works you know what i mean especially
when it comes to women when me my
brother and my dad sort of get together
and we have these conversations my dad
is very blue pill right but he's a good
man he raised this both really really
well but when we're having these kind of
man-to-man talks regarding like women
and like lifestyle like my dad would
just say some [ __ ] and like even my
brother will look at me like my
brother's a bit of a blue-pilled alpha i
think but like we'll just kind of look
at each other and be like
what are you talking about but i don't
know if that's from a different
generational thing or maybe he was
raised differently he was raised very
feminine at some point they will get it
at some point they will get it you know
the teacher will always appear when a
student becomes ready and for most and
for most guys it's after chaos
you know they have to experience chaos
there has to be some kind of like um
nicholas talim tell up i can't remember
his full name but he wrote the book
anti-fragile and he talks about black
swan events you know sort of thing it's
like the thing
what's that
like harvard yeah
kind of like code but i mean like you
know to the point of like for most men
personally a black swan event you know
for a guy would be
you know just use my example you know
you overly invest into a relationship
where
she sees you as a utility and you've cut
yourself raising another man's uh
children you know i made that stupid mix
mistake right and it's like all of a
sudden now you know you're dealing in a
black swan event where you know the
chick that you invest all your time and
resources and her and her kids is now
porking some other guy because you have
a disagreement right and she lies about
it you know sort of thing so it's like
you know it's these black swan events
that will send guys over the edge and
then seeking you know the truth the same
thing happened with my divorce the same
thing happened in my business when i was
dealing with lobbying issues with the
credit card companies in the ontario
government with the legislative changes
sort of thing it's like you know there's
going to be a sequence of events in a
man's life where
a safe world theory that you hold that
you rely on for
your own um
safe operation you know if you will it's
like having your legs taken out from
underneath you you know sort of thing
it's like
okay so that thing that i was leaning on
no longer supports me
now now i'm on the [ __ ] ground what
happened because i completely invested
in that belief right and that's kind of
like the black swan event that i was
like you know mentioning earlier it's
it's the chaos that drives men into into
seeking
this knowledge so you can't force it
down your you know down there so like
one of the first things that most guys
do is they're like you know like a guy
like you as the older brother will show
your younger brother a couple of clips
and say check out this guy and he's like
who's this bald bearded loser i'm not
listening to this you know it looks like
literally what happened basically yeah
you know at some point some some [ __ ]
will go sideways in their life and
they'll come back and they'll be like
you know what that bald beard guy is
right
yeah even with friends of mine and stuff
like that they go through some
relationship stuff like
i've made a mistake in the past of like
maybe blabbing on about the red pill a
little bit too much maybe in a public
setting right because i do feel it's a
little bit of a superpower but
yeah now that i've got a little bit more
experience i just i just see [ __ ] i just
kind of keep to myself like like you
said if people don't want the help they
don't want the help you know yeah that's
it yeah yeah i mean like you can drop a
couple sound bites see if they respond
if they're non-responsive all right cool
you know have fun
simping for that you know
enjoy
cool
awesome man keep up the good work and uh
yeah all the best thanks bruno
appreciate it hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you